today we're going to talk about
the oh my goodness the deeper source of
your fatigue now I will say this I am an
expert in this area simply because I've
been tired a good portion of my life and
I overcame it so I have something very
important I want to share I remember
driving down the street with my wife in
my late 20s being completely exhausted
trying to find a healthy store to find
some vitamin to give me energy it never
worked I had tons and tons of vitamins
and did know what was going on so if I
can teleport this video back in time and
show it to myself this video would have
solved my problem if I really understood
how the body makes energy and also this
is going to be very motivating to you
especially because you're going to
finally understand what really is behind
fatigue in general because you can take
various vitamins and energy drinks and
try to boost your energy and and more
coffee but that doesn't fix the real
problem and if you go to any of these
7-Elevens you'll see right at the front
counter this huge section 5H Hour Energy
Drinks everything starts with this
mitochondria what is the mitochondria
it's an energy Factory deep inside your
cells that produces energy if you have
any aspects of fatigue even if you
exercise and you run out of gas really
fast or even if you have many of the
different problems the health problems
that most people have this mitochondria
is at the root of it in fact most
diseases come directly from this
mitochondria so what is the pondria it's
a battery making machine because food
directly can't give you energy it has to
be converted into a chemical form of a
battery so you can use it and so the
energy battery itself is called
ATP so the mitochondria is actually the
battery maker and the ATP is the actual
battery and whether you took
biochemistry or not this might help you
to understand the Simplicity of what's
going on with the massive complexity of
what's Happening inside that
mitochondria maybe you have or you
haven't heard about this Krebs cycle
thing right that's actually the pre-
battery maker okay so it comes right
before the battery maker Because the
actual battery maker is connected to it
the kreb cycle gets everything prepared
and ready and helps strip out some of
these electrons but we have to somehow
extract these electrons from the food
that you eat and since we're on the
topic of food certain foods have more
energy than other foods and so if you're
living on Ultra processed foods it's
going to be almost impossible to extract
energy from that simply because it's
dead there's not a lot of energy in
there and on top of that there's a lot
of nutritional factors in food that we
need that the battery maker assembly
line requires in each step of the
assembly line okay you need B1 B2 B3
folic acid B12 magnesium manganese
selenium vitamin C and something else
called co-enzyme Q10 so these are the
helper molecules that are essential for
making this battery now there's a very
very important enzyme that's involved in
making ATP it's called ATP synthes not
that you needed to know that but what's
interesting about this ATP enzyme is
that it's very very tiny and it's a
turbine it spins it helps to generate
energy but it's it's very very tiny okay
so it would take like a 100,000 of these
little enzymes to be the same width as
one hair okay so they're that tiny but
they're spinning at an incredible speed
and every time they rotate one rotation
they produce three atps and so how fast
do they rotate well they're rotating
roughly about 7,000 to 9,000 rotations
every every single minute so you can
imagine how much ATP is generated I mean
just one enzyme you're talking like
27,000 atps per minute now if we just
look at one cell and determine how many
mitochondria is in that one cell you're
looking at on average between a, to
2500 mitochondria per cell and how many
cells do you have in your body you have
10 trillion cells incredible now check
this out a healthy person makes a
massive amount of ATP the actual weight
of that ATP would be equivalent to your
own weight so if I weigh 180 pounds I
make 180 pounds of ATP every single day
that would be equivalent to 12200 Watts
which comes out to about 282 AA
batteries now that might not seem like a
lot of wattage but your body is very
efficient at using this energy but the
fascinating thing about this ATP is it's
not really stored it's generated on
demand so if you're not really
exercising or moving you're not going to
generate nearly as much as if you were
exercising the point is that this ATP
doesn't really get stored now when it's
used okay it turns into ADP which then
can be recycled back to ATP and ADP does
get stored but ADP gets recycled about a
thousand times a day okay into ATP and
so at any given time during the day you
have really only a quarter of a kilogram
of ATP that's not that much but as soon
as you start exercising that ATP
generation goes way way way up now the
next question is if we don't uh store
ATP what energy do we store well there's
two fuel sources you have sugar stored
as glycogen in your muscle in your liver
which it's not really that much it's
probably have 1,700 calories worth of
stored glycogen and soon as you deplete
it your body is going to require more
sugar or glycogen if you're dependent on
that sugar but you also store energy as
fat and once your fat adapted you can
tap into this fat a lot easier because
you've grooved into this ketosis by
lowering your carbohydrates and you
become very efficient at burning fat
then you can very easily use that fat as
energy and have that go through this KB
cycle but if you're not fat adapted um
you're going to run out of energy pretty
quick because you haven't adapted to the
fat fuel you're just going to run out of
energy and so this is why the ketogenic
diet is so important for your energy
first of all you get more ATP from
ketones and fat then you do glycogen or
sugar and secondly you have a lot of fat
uh Reserve to tap into I mean the
average person who's not overweight has
about a 100,000 calories of of fat on
their body compared to the glycogen
storage which is only like 1,700 enough
for one day so with my problem way back
when I was in my late 20s I would
consume pure carbohydrates okay and my
energy would come up when I would eat
and then it would come crashing down
because I ran out of energy and I
required more sugar or more carbs to get
my energy I was completely dependent on
carbs I didn't know about ketosis back
then but I was always tired especially
in my head even when I would wake up in
the morning I would be so tired and I
couldn't wake up like mentally until
later in the morning or even the midday
so what's significant about that is that
70% of all your ATP is used by your
brain your brain Hogs a lot of this ATP
so if there's not enough of this ATP to
go around for various reasons your
brain's going to suffer and this is is
why we have so many problems with
dementia add brain degenerative
disorders mood disorders I mean try to
be depressed when you have a lot of
energy available with your mitochondria
it's it's virtually impossible if you
reflect back on the times that you were
depressed chances are you were also
tired at the same time so the first clue
about getting energy is to get on the
ketogenic diet so then you can supply
your body with a quick source of fuel
which is more efficient to you can not
only make more ATP but then so you can
tap into this energy reserve a lot
quicker and not be stuck uh with this
machine that's only dependent on glucose
as your fuel it's dependent on co-actors
yeah research now has shown that the
primary source of oxidative stress in
cells is leakage of oxygen and these
electrons from the mitochondria and this
leakage increases when the key nutrients
or protective molecules are missing in
like co-enzyme Q10 especially if the
person's taking a Statin drug or other
drugs that deplete that nutrient that's
a really important nutrient to help
transport electrons now just so happens
that that biochemical pathway that
involves the co-enzyme Q10 which is
needed to generate energy um is the same
pathway that we make cholesterol and so
the drug Statin which basically inhibits
that enzyme also inhibits Coen have Q10
and this is why one of the biggest side
effects from people taking statins
involves muscle uh problems weak muscles
inflamed muscles muscle disorders lack
of energy because think about just in
general uh your muscles need energy to
function I mean this is how we move you
can't move without muscles so you can
imagine how much mitochondri is in your
muscles and how much Coenzyme Q10 that
we need in our muscles in fact if you
wanted to consume something with high
amounts of co-enzyme Q10 you want to eat
muscle okay like red meat fish things
like that and the food that has the
highest amount would be organ Meats
liver and especially heart okay extract
you can probably get in supplements but
you know people don't typically eat
heart but um it's something that has a
lot of coin Q10 but you have to also
realize that your body makes co-enzyme
Q10 so it's not just necessarily
dependent on the diet you can make it as
well if you have all the co-actors that
allow it to be generated and so all
those co-actors especially B vitamins
are needed to allow coenzyme Q10 to work
so just as a side note uh if you're on a
Statin if you're on a beta blocker if
you're on some medication for diabetes
chances are your coenzyme Q10 is very
very low so you should start taking that
there's an interesting study um that I
will put down below um about EXC
exercise they tested like athletes
versus people who don't exercise okay
and they gave them Coen mq10 so in both
groups they found significant
Improvement in endurance so you can go
longer without being tired and now you
know why because that Coen and Q10 is
necessary in the generation of ATP as
well as acting as an an oxident to
protect you against all this free
radical damage that's created from the
exercise so one big side effect from
statins too is you just run out of gas
really quick especially if you exert
yourself or you exercise now as far as
the food that you should be eating you
want food that contains a lot of
electrons and a lot of life and a lot of
energy so you can extract the energy
from that if you're consuming like with
the average American consumes processed
foods I think it's 83% of all the
calories in the grocery store are Ultra
processed foods they don't even resemble
the actual food it's going to be
literally impossible to get energy if
you're eating those Foods so so we want
nutrient-dense foods with red meat at
the top of the list I will tell you when
I have red meat I have more energy it's
not just the iron that that helps build
up my hemoglobin there's a lot of other
factors in that meat that give me energy
not just Coen mq10 but just a lot of
energy generating factors there's
another interesting study about this I
just found this I think it's fascinating
I will put the link down below but what
they did is they wanted to test the
nutrition factors in red meat okay
versus the plant-based meats that
they're coming up with now like the
artificial meats and so if you look at
the nutrition labels on both of them
they look very similar right look
healthy but what they found is out of
190 biomarkers they found
171 out of one for 90 were significantly
higher than the plant-based fake meat
type uh food if you want to call it that
the point is that when you eat
nutrient-dense foods like truly
nutrient-dense Foods uh there's 's a lot
of things in there that can actually
help you get healthy and instead of
trying to make food just taste good I
would focus on trying to help grow your
food that's more nutrient dense and eat
more food that is nutrient dense because
what they're trying to do with the fake
meat now is just to try to mimic the
taste of it the texture of it but what
about the nutrition the other really
really really important thing about um
your mitochondria and actually producing
more mitochondria is exercise hands down
that is the number one way to reduce
more mitochondria this is another reason
why you should consistently exercise on
a regular basis and that's going to
override a lot of other bad things that
you might have done in your past and
also if you have any type of diseases or
uh problems currently this can help um
counter that why because a lot of
disease comes from damage to the
mitochondria and if you're exercising
and you're making more and combine that
with in a minute fasting that fasting
triggers another thing called autophagy
autophagy is recycling old damaged
proteins but also the recycling of the
mitochondria how cool is that and then
you're creating new mitochondria this is
how you're going to get more energy this
is the stuff that I wish I knew back in
my early 20s actually before that I wish
I knew this in kindergarten I would have
saved uh myself a lot of years of
fatigue now a couple other things that
could increase your mitochondria
Cal therapy I do that on a regular basis
and man do I feel better after doing it
if you're a little hesitant at doing
that you can do kind of like a partial
cold immersion with a cold shower the
most difficult part about this is when
you submerge um around your heart
because your heart is pumping and it's
trying to keep you warm and it's kind of
like the the most vulnerable area but
you can always do half of your body cold
and you'll get some benefits from that
there's also phytonutrients that can
increase increase the reproduction of
mitochondria and actually help repair
some of the mitochondria as well like
sulfurane and the cruciferous vegetables
and the broccoli mic grains as well as
the radish micro grains it's a lot of
different foods there actually are quite
a few phytonutrients that when you
consume those they help your
mitochondria and then on the flip side
it's avoiding certain things too like
avoiding the refined Foods avoiding the
sugar going on keto avoiding chronic
stress heavy metals smoking alcohol
these are all the things I wish I would
have known back in my 20s and also this
is the understanding of what the
mitochondria really is now because of
the censoring and the suppressing of the
algorithms on YouTube it's becoming more
difficult to find my content and there's
a lot of content that I cannot put on
YouTube unfortunately so to make sure
you have full access of all my
information go to drberg.com And
subscribe to my newsletter by clicking
the link Down Below in the description I
will see you on the other side now I
touched on this co-enzyme Q10 thing if
you haven't seen this video check it out
it's pretty
interesting